BROADCOM:
When you think of the largest tech companies
in the world, what names come to mind?
Probably Apple, Microsoft, Google, Nvidia,
Amazon, and Meta right?
Well, what about Broadcom?
Did you know that Broadcom is currently the
9th largest tech company in the world?
In fact, they boast a market cap of $570 billion.
Broadcom has been one of those background
companies that has grown way larger and way
more powerful that anyone realized.
I mean, just take a look at their stock graph,
it’s basically a rocket ship having grown
74X since late 2009 alone.
For perspective, even Apple has only grown
32x during that time period, and it’s the
same story with the rest of big tech as well.
Microsoft only grew 17x, Google only grew
13x, and Facebook has only grown 10x.
They only big tech company that has really
outshined Broadcom in terms of growth is Nvidia
who’s stock graph is an even bigger rocket
ship having grown 177x during the same time
period.
But, there’s one massive difference between
Nvidia and Broadcom.
For quite some time now, Nvidia has been involved
in multiple super hyped up industries whether
it be crypto mining, self driving cars, or
most recently language models.
Apple literally created the iPhone, and Google,
Facebook, and Microsoft created or acquired
services that are used by billions of people.
But Broadcom on the other hand?
Well, that’s as boring and background as
it gets.
That’s why they’ve been able to grow to
nearly being a top 10 company without the
general public noticing.
But, that doesn't mean that you should take
Broadcom lightly.
Broadcom estimates that 99% of all internet
traffic across the entire world passes through
at least one Broadcom chip, and they’ve
produced quite a few skeletons to get to that
point.
In fact, just recently, they completed their
acquisition of VMWare for $69 billion which
has turned into one of the most controversial
acquisitions within the tech world.
So, here’s what you need to know about Broadcom,
the truth about how they got so large, and
why people in the know are so worried about
Broadcom.
MAKING A NAME:
Taking a look back, Broadcom has been somewhat
of a dark horse within the tech industry since
the very beginning way back in 1961.
One of the main reasons for this is that Broadcom
was never some sort of humble startup that
was cherished by its consumers at any point
in time.
Rather, they were started in the shadows and
they stayed in the shadows.
You see, Broadcom was originally started as
a division of within HP in 1961 called HP
Associates.
1961 was very much the stone ages when it
comes to tech world, but by this point, HP
had already made a name for themselves having
been in business since 1939.
They were known for making cutting edge audio
oscillators and radar technology that were
famously used by Disney and the US military
during World War 2 respectively.
As such, Broadcom, or HP Associates, was launched
with a great pedigree and plenty of resources,
but for the first 30 years you wouldn’t
have even known that they existed.
In fact, Broadcom’s own corporate history
page only a few bullet points describing the
first 30 years of business which really just
centers on 3 inventions.
The first of these inventions was gallium
aresnide phosphide LEDs.
These LEDs are what you see at traffic lights
and big LED signs.
Their second invention also had to do with
LEDs.
They were the ones who created the world’s
first commercially available LED dot matrix
displays.
And lastly, moving into the 1970s, they also
created the first fiber optic transmitters
and receivers.
These 3 inventions provided them with plenty
of business behind the scenes especially when
combined with the brand image of HP.
But, this is not what really made Broadcom
into what it is today.
For that, we have to fast forward to the early
1990s to the early days of the internet.
You see, while all of the VCs and entrepreneur
hopefuls were piling into the internet space
hoping to make it big, one professor student
pair named Henry Samueli and Henry Nicholas
at UCLA would decide to sell the shovels.
If the internet was truly gonna become the
next big thing, everyone was surely gonna
need a way to connect and get access to the
network, and this is precisely what this duo
would address.
Together they would found a small private
company called Broadcom in 1991 and they would
begin developing integrated circuits that
made the internet.
If you’ve ever wondered how in the world
it was possible to get an internet connection
using cable TV lines, well, you can thank
these guys.
Unlike HP Associates, these guys didn’t
really have a reputation or connections.
It was really just the quality of their invention
that did all the talking.
Their first few customers themselves included
the likes of Time Warner, Rockwell International,
Analog Devices, and even the US Air Force.
These customers alone would provide Broadcom
with over $5 million in annual revenue and
attract the attention of Intel who would loan
the company another $5 million.
And if you’re wondering what all the hubbub
was about, then I think these numbers will
really put things in perspective.
At the time, phone based internet offered
speeds of up to 28.8 kilobits per second.
Broadcom's cable based solutions on the other
hand offered speeds of up to 1000 times that.
And they would soon move over to revolutionizing
the phone internet space as well.
Hearing all this, you’re probably wondering
where all the controversy is.
So far, this is relly just a feel good story
about ingenuity and innovation that made the
whole internet what it is today.
And it definitely could’ve been exactly
that, but pretty soon, our profesor student
duo would lose their way after seeing big
dollar signs.
A DARK HORSE:
By 1998, Broadcom would grow to 11,750 employees
across 15 countries and they would go public
with an insanely successful IPO that made
the founders into centi millionaires.
They could’ve just held onto their stakes
for the long term and they would’ve become
deca billionaires but what they wanted was
a larger portion of the pie leading us into
one of the biggest stock scandals of the era:
options backdating.
Options backdating was an extremely prevalent
scandal throughout the late 90s and early
2000s and it involved the likes of Apple,
UnitedHealth Group, Staples, The Cheesecake
Factory, KB Homes, Monster, and of course
Broadcom.
How does it work you ask?
Well, it was all due to one misguided accounting
rule that was implemented in 1972.
The rule permitted companies to avoid disclosing
executive compensation if it was in the form
of stock options.
This wasn’t a big deal at the time or for
the next 25 years really because stock options
weren’t nearly as popular back in the day.
But that would all change with the rise of
dotcom companies.
All of sudden, billion dollar fortunes were
being minted overnight thanks to stock compensation.
So, naturally, stock compensation became far
more desirable than cash compensation and
pretty soon these executives would discover
a loophole within the law.
Given that companies didn’t have to disclose
stock option grants to investors at the time
in which they were granted, the whole system
essentially ran off the honor system.
It was up to the executives to be honest about
how much stock compensation they received
and when.
But let’s just say that a lot of tech executives
weren’t exactly honest.
Essentially, they would team up with their
executive buddies and create false paperwork
that made it seem like they all received a
bunch of stock grants 5 years ago when the
stock was 50 times cheaper.
And it was now up to the investors to pay
out these massive compensations through the
form of stock dilution.
This practice would end up costing investors
over $10 billion, $2.2 billion of which was
“allegedly” due to none other than Broadcom.
After these revelations come to light, both
founders would step away from the company
but they were never really held accountable.
The cases against them would eventually be
dropped due to “prosecutorial misconduct”
and Broadcom would end up settling for just
$160 million.
Both founders would end up walking away as
deca billionaires but this scandal would forever
stain Broadcom and turn them into the dark
horse that they are today.
After this massive scandal, Broadcom very
much needed a way to reset and move forward
and this is where the other half of Broadcom
would come into play.
Remember how we started off this story talking
about HP Associates?
Well, this is where they would become relevant.
Right before the turn of the century, HP Associates
would break off from HP and become a new company
called Agilent Technologies.
This company would then be purchased by KKR
and Silver Lake Partners in 2005 for $2.7
billion, creating a new company called Avago
Technologies.
Avago lurk around the shadows of the tech
world for the next decade before they finally
made their big move in 2015.
They would agree to move forward and acquire
the entirety of the stained Broadcom for $37
billion bringing us into the modern day Broadcom.
A SHADOW GIANT:
Honestly, there’s really nothing good to
say about the modern Broadcom which is such
a shame.
These guys are literally responsible for creating
the tech that makes the modern internet possible,
yet their behavior really makes it hard to
root for them.
For starters, it appears that they're patent
trolls.
In 2017, for example, they sued smart TV makers
for patent infringement.
And in 2020, they sued Netflix also for patent
infringement.
Though the tech community at large just views
these lawsuits as Broadcom suing because their
jealous.
Even the judge that was ruling on the case
said quote “You’re killing me” calling
the filings “massive overkill”.
But, their patent tantrums are the least of
your worries.
The far bigger issue is that Broadcom controls
the entire internet chip market.
Calling them a monopoly is honestly understating
the situation.
Again keep in mind, according to Broadcom
themselves, 99% of all internet traffic passes
through their chips, so basically every company
that you can think of in the entire world
is reliant on Broadcom, and I’m not just
talking about tech companies.
Broadcom has fortune 500 customers in all
of these industries.
And let’s just say Broadcom is very much
a predatory service provider for these customers.
You know, things like predatory contracts,
retaliation on non loyal customers, exclusivity
arrangements and so on.
I mean, you can’t feel too bad for these
Fortune 500 customers because they usually
turn around and do the exact same thing to
us, but the point still stands that Broadcom
is very much a toxic force within the tech
world.
They control an invention that basically everyone
needs and they leverage that to the max.
And more recently, they’ve been looking
to expand their monopoly to adjacent sectors.
In 2017, for example, they would attempt a
hostile takeover of the mobile chipmaker Qualcomm
for $105 billion.
The only reason this deal didn’t go through
is because President Trump would block it.
But, it’s not like Broadcom was really all
that upset about it because they would just
move on to their next acquisition target.
In mid 2018, for example, Broadcom would go
ahead and purchase CA technologies, a tech
infrastructure giant, for $18.9 billion in
cash.
And most recently, they completed their acquisition
of VMWare for $69 billion.
Every time that Broadcom completes an acquisition,
they make sure to spread their toxicity, and
that’s why much of the tech community has
basically just accepted that VMWare is basically
dead.
It’s very similar to what GE was doing back
in the 80s and 90s but instead of it happening
in the industrial world, it’s happening
in the tech world.
And honestly, the only way that this will
likely end is by Broadcom becoming so big
and so toxic that they crumble from the inside
out.
Until then though, they’re very much a force
to be reckoned with and that is the truth
about Broadcom.
Someone else who has been investing a bunch
into acquisitions is none other than Microsoft,
and it may end up backfiring.
Check out this video to learn more.